welcome to this video super saiyajin
have played this guy a number of times
already from Hungary Hungarian flag yeah
I'm going for them for the chabanenko
sloth is playing the old the old main
line really like it was like it was
played when the line was just getting
popular question the only problem is I
have forgotten how it is really played I
think Quincy 7 still it is possible him
I don't really have a problem here with
the C file if i remember correctly
yeah I think even King takes valid yeah
I think this is how it is played before
yeah you for it's not a big issue anyway
okay okay yeah I can the thing is I
thought I can just just ignore all that
oh is this too passive the situation
maybe I can also play a five takes nine
ticks not sure that it six is a big
problem but ok this should be it should
be a all right now I wants to go to age
6 ok let's block this
now I can take what I try it but there's
also quite a weakness now even the 97 as
possible I mean queen age 60 also bishop
evade this is not a problem it is at a
passer of course
this is a bit passive yes anyway I need
to scout the plane maybe trade on the c
final queen 85 this is type of type of
counter play pawn takes all night takes
your pawn takes I guess very
straightforward what is staying if I
take a 2 now and I have possibly Queen
d2 yeah h4 isn't this isn't this an
issue here Queen takes Queen d2 and I'm
invading him I don't know the night
moves i have night f5 and I'm just
better this looked weird to me this
Queen g5 home for this they maybe he
doesn't have a problem he have it isn't
this here just
just okay from you know what what is
then what is the big point i have this
chick here on you one or queen III a
queen III is also quite gotten so it's a
pen and b3 hangs so Roxy tool there is
what there is night f1 okay that's still
interested
oxy to my turf one hi this is this is
very tricky I've Knight a5 coming
I'm not sure about the best setup here
if night f5 bishop age six this is quite
nice for me but hard to determine what's
the best setup is got this this awful
pieces so check
Queen c3 just go King d7 and protect
everything and then I'm coming with the
pieces Bishop age six and stuff
it's got Queen g-form maybe two to
defend there's some way to avoid this
may be okay don't want to maybe maybe
here
time warning
Quincy to coming yeah in a position
where you would would like to have more
time here maybe as it all covered I
think it's are quite amazing but maybe
it is the case just is just amazing that
he sees got everything covered him
yeah I was totally in his position I
mean really really a really strange
would be able to be interesting to look
at afterwards there was so there were
some chances i'm pretty sure Tim not
sure what this is him at the moment I'm
covering the h-bond and I don't see how
he's coming forward yeah I don't have
much time check i take c 6 with chicken
yeah yeah what the frustrating game this
is really frustrating he basically
outplayed himself and then I returned
the favor black resigns yeah i wrote
around here with Queen d2 black is just
winning them and minus for you it's no
big surprise if I must have played like
a total [ __ ] here and not winning this
so Queen g1 is winning let's check let's
check how exactly what happens after
after look everyone I then be three
hangs I know you fancy a bishop see one
Luke see one ok yeah it must be winning
and he just totally let me enter his
position miss placing all pieces Queen
on h4 night on g3 it's a check yeah I
went here this only keeps an edge but
it's not a winning check and this is
winning our it since I'm attacking with
our pieces now d for also hangs and
something like this
okay the way it was plate yeah before us
also a look-see to is winning why it why
am I not winning in this position
Queenie one is strong ah this pin the
other pin okay okay okay Queenie one is
the point Queen even yeah I can not now
it's almost stalemated he has no moves
them threatening rook b-2s knows this to
cover it for the moment but I have this
this and this and this is the the just
punishment further for the play okay I
went here and I'm still clearly better
but check I really screwed this up
around here I must have screwed it up
completely Queen h7 still winning still
winning him clean age seven then the
problem is really he has these dead
pieces and the totally totally screwed
up structure so it really should be an
attack for me I just don't see how I
enter the position the computer is
saying I'm clearly better and I don't
they don't see though how I enter like
this is a line and how do i enter Queen
h8c 8 back on the C file yeah maybe this
year I have a fairly there's the
structure is very reliable on the Kings
side so maybe this is really the point
was still a substantial edge from him
but right yet it's already already
already tricky oops
yeah he's got this and five move coming
here must play a five myself here mmhmm
yeah yeah Queen takes but i really was
panicking a bit him and this is of
course not not any edge anymore i guess
he's got the h porn and the snow gets
gets to be a strength yeah here here
this is strictly to play Queen g6 is
silver yeah I was far too irritate it to
change this position and not have
anything even this is still raw this is
losing with Queen Jayde king yeah its
third also i don't know it's not not
really relevant here the computer will
of course find many improvements is this
what you really played in a strange
fashion I mean around here it's clear
that white is better yeah I just I just
played it played in battle here on the
King side but he kick QE h 7 is very
strong queen age 78 I guess this is this
i don't i don't really understand why
why should you play in three seconds
this Queen g5 move and queen edge
freud's it's a critical position and
it's not like why this is totally
winning or anything here and it's
everything's easy yeah here black is
already better and TM winning with Queen
d2 so why did he play this in like two a
second and move I don't I don't know I
was really worse before really worse
before yeah I guess I don't know I don't
know really this you for business maybe
I have some I must play Queen be 75 must
play Queen B 7 first I think to be able
to capture with the Queen maybe yeah
it's possible it's possible here this is
it's already a bit a bit of this
position may be Queen B 6 is strong
I am so that this is possible of course
you will not play five but just to
coordinate pieces better okay well
thanks for watching